alors évidemment beaucoup dans l'action
depuis depuis ce matin nous étions tout
à l'heure avec bamako où l'on a suivi
avec beaucoup d'intérêt cette
intervention du chef de l'état nous
étions au cycle correspondant à
ouagadougou le burkina faso un pays où
faut-il le rappeler les militaires se
sont également là aussi installer mais
où il continue à discuter à coopérer
avec les autorités françaises allons
allons voir du côté du sénégal
maintenant à l'heure où beaucoup
s'inquiètent d'une expansion des forces
jihadistes dans la région sahel on
retrouve tout de suite sarah sakho en
direct de dakar bonjour sahara qu'est-ce
que peut sans changer en ce ce départ et
ce redéploiement pour le sénégal demain
goûter potentiellement beaucoup de
choses mais il est encore très tôt pour
se prononcer vous l'avez dit encore
beaucoup de flou autour de ce
redéploiement des français et des
européens dans le sahel et cela aura
évidemment des conséquences pour le
sénégal mais comme on a encore beaucoup
d'incertitudes il est difficile de
savoir en quoi exactement cela va
changer la situation alors le sénégal
pour l'instant contribuer au contingent
de la minus mas est donc présent au mali
mais il ne fait pas partie par exemple
du g5 sahel et non plus de l'accord
d'accra vous savez qui concerne les pays
côtiers du golfe de guinée est ce que la
coopération entre le sénégal et la
france va s'accroître est ce que le
sénégal va envoyer plus de troupes dans
le sahel ce sont des questions que qu'on
est en droit de se poser à présent mais
auquel on n'a pas encore de réponse
évidemment ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que le sénégal est concerné par la
menace jihadiste dans la région comme
tous les pays de l'afrique de l'ouest il
n'y a eu aucun attentat pour l'instant
c'est donc une menace contenu pour
l'heure mais le sénégalais concernés et
ce depuis des années donc une
dégradation de la situation en main lire
aura forcément des conséquences
ici au sénégal
dakar général